the only way on earth to influence
other people is to talk about what they
want
and show them how to get it that's true
the only way on earth to influence other
people is to talk about what
they want and to show them how
to get it it's not self-obsession it's
viewer obsession welcome to the think
marketing podcast
my name is heather torres and you are
listening to the number one
podcast to help you grow your influence
on youtube
and then turn that influence into a high
impact and high
profit online business and i'm excited
because today's episode
is all about how to build 1 million
subscribers for me
i'm always curious how do highly
successful people
actually do it some of my favorite
podcasts to listen to
are the journey the story but i want to
know the tactics and the strategies that
they don't normally share and that's
what today's episode
is all about and today's special episode
is brought to you by
grow with video live and i'm excited
because we're doing
a giveaway to win an all-access pass to
this year's upcoming virtual conference
in fall of 2021 and i'll tell you more
about that
after today's featured content with sean
cannell let's get into
the meat and potatoes of today's podcast
[Music]
i'm excited to get into this episode
because i've really never shared these
10 tips
anywhere else before and talked about
some of the
unconventional strategies and really
energy that has gone into
growing my youtube channel to over a
million subscribers you know today
i have a couple different youtube
channels one just hit a hundred thousand
another one's over six hundred thousand
and
think media is now at 1.5 million and
now it's a team of creators but
you know it all started from zero and
you might be
at zero today you may be just getting
started and i believe this is gonna be
one of the most
important episodes you ever listened to
about youtube because
this is the kind of stuff that really
nobody talks about and towards the end
of the episode
i'm gonna be actually revealing some
very important tactical things
that you can apply but here's the big
idea
how do you build a one million
subscriber youtube channel
one subscriber at a time you got to
remember
that it's not about getting a million
subscribers it's actually about getting
one subscriber and when you change your
thinking you can really change your life
and your youtube channel when you change
your thinking to think man if i can make
a difference in
one person's life if i can make a
difference and gain
one viewer if i can actually get more
than a view but if i can get a super fan
if i can make a real
impact in someone's life then chances
are they may tell somebody else
and actually chances are that if one
viewer really enjoys this content
that the youtube algorithm will identify
that and start sharing it
with other viewers like them and
there are other places where we go deep
into the tactics
of youtube and i encourage you to
subscribe so that you can hear all of
those but
this one's really actually about people
and i'll explain some practical ways to
connect with people but here's my belief
people matter most it's all about people
people come first
and even profit comes second even growth
comes second that if the people are
first
and you're guess what it's not about
your youtube channel it's not about
your subscribers it's actually about the
people that are subscribing
and are you thinking about them first
and serving
them first foundationally i believe that
the reason i was able to
grow to over a million subscribers was
because i was
obsessed and am still obsessed with
the viewer are you obsessed with the
viewer
are you thinking more about your self
you know there's two types of content i
see on youtube i see selfish content
and i see service content and i think
there's a big mistake people make
because we see a few
mark my words a few social media
influencers that are self-obsessed
that it's all about them and that
they're fascinating
enough or beautiful enough or
unique enough or whatever that people
want to watch
their life but i've learned that the
practical way to grow on youtube
is to not think about selfish content
but think about service content i hear
people say we coach people all the time
i just kind of like share my thoughts on
youtube i just kind of make a a channel
about my life
and here's the deal that might work but
let me ask you
are you doing it through the frame of
what value is it going to add to the
viewer
are you doing it through the frame of is
this going to
serve the viewer even if it's
entertainment or if it's education
is it going to serve the viewer and
here's a truth
the only way on earth to influence
other people is to talk about what
they want and show them how to get it
that's true the only way on earth to
influence other people is to talk about
what they
want and to show them how
to get it it's not self-obsession it's
viewer obsession because the truth is
good content will
help you get views but truly caring and
making meaningful connections will help
you build a
lasting youtube legacy of course
to get to a million subscribers you need
good content
of course sean well what about the
channel that got a viral video and they
got a million subscribers
but here's my question where are they
gonna be in five to ten years
are they just getting views or are they
building a
real legacy you know there's a famous
article from steven uh kevin kelly
that's called a thousand true fans my
friend pat flynn kind of did a spin-off
and wrote a book called
super fans which popularized and went
deeper
on that concept and it was this idea
that actually to make a full-time living
as an entrepreneur
an artist a creator a photographer you
only need a thousand true fans
a thousand true passionate customers a
thousand true passionate viewers
and that mathematically if every year
those a thousand true fans spent
one hundred dollars with you that would
be one hundred thousand dollars a year
in
income but here's the deal it's not
about your income it's about your
influence and impact in their lives and
because that's so profound and so
impactful that they
are delighted to do business with you or
to go deeper with you with your products
your services or
your youtube content and that math can
scale to whatever you want it could be
2 000 true fans and 50 a year it could
be
10 000 true fans but again it's true
fans these are people you've made a
meaningful connection with
and so in just a second i'm going to
share 10 ways to make meaningful
connections and grow your
channel one subscriber at a time but i
do want to recommend a book to you
that's super famous if you've never read
it this is one you definitely want to
check out this year
and it's by dale carnegie and it's
called how to win
friends and influence people okay of
course you can always check
out the show notes in the description
for links to any of the resources we
recommend
but here's a couple principles from this
famous book that has stood the test in
time of people that want to
build businesses come on build social
media influence
come on build powerful marketing come on
build powerful non-profits or movements
that people who really have influence
understand
what dale carnegie teaches in this book
and here's one of the principles
become genuinely interested in other
people
wow like is your obsession
with the viewer and is it just a tactic
or are you
genuinely interested in other people
it's one of the things
he talks about in the book it actually
kind of reminds me of a bible verse
where
you know one of the early church
planners of christianity was the apostle
paul
and he had a disciple kind of a protege
and his name was timothy
and there's this verse in philippians
chapter 2 where he says
i have no one else like timothy
who genuinely cares about your welfare
all others care only for themselves
come on that'll preach like think about
it i have no one else he was like man
i'm so
impressed with timothy because he
genuinely cares about the people
in this philippian church and he's like
everybody else guess what they care
about themselves
and so if you want to create a movement
and build a legacy on youtube what would
happen
if not even just tactically but actually
very personally and dare i say even
spiritually you
really got obsessed and cared about
the viewer at the deepest level like you
went the extra mile
to say i'm not gonna make selfish
content i'm going to make
service content and listen
you can get everything in the world that
you want if you will just help other
people
get what they want i really believe that
this isn't
but completely punting your needs you
need money for the mission
you want to grow your youtube channel
you want to build your influence great
what order are you doing it in are you
trying to put yourself
first or are you trying to put the
viewer first from your content
ideas from your strategy from your time
from your energy
and so when i think about how i've
behaved over the last
year uh 10 years and growing my various
youtube channels and
growing my social media platforms i have
tried to keep this front and center and
listen i'm not trying to come at you
from a pedestal or preach at you from a
soapbox
i of course have selfish tendencies but
i keep this front and center
and i keep adjusting my attention and
checking my heart and
making sure man i want to stay obsessed
with the viewer and here's some things
that i've done this is like what it
really takes this is the hustle i put in
this is the energy i put in
this is the things that i did here's 10
things and these are 10 ways to make
meaningful connections and grow your
channel one subscriber at a time number
one
answer every comment from the day i
started youtube
i made it a goal to answer every comment
now you may have heard this before but
are you really doing it are you
answering
every comment and when you answer the
comment are you just kind of like giving
it a little
fist bump or are you actually
potentially going deeper if the person
asks a question
will you take the time to write a
sentence or two or three or four
to serve and connect with that person in
the youtube
comments let me remind you your youtube
empire grows one subscriber at a time
and maybe if you're going this path sean
i just want to go viral i don't actually
like connect with anybody that's one
approach i suppose
but what i think is about what what if
you actually really make a meaningful
connection with one person a day
you know that'd be 365 people a year and
that first year you'd have all these
meaningful connections to people being
like wow that was so
amazing man that i love that channel i
love that creator i love that business
owner i love that entrepreneur man
i can just feel the love through the
platform you know if you were able to do
that
what would the word start to spread or
even if you
just did that for four years you would
have
over a thousand super fans right i don't
know what the math is 360 times four
something around 1200 1300 if you just
again you might get 10 views 100 views a
thousand views but what if you got one
super fan a day
because you were connected with a lot of
people but you really made meaningful
connections
answer every comment number one number
two
use people's name when you reply to
their comments
well how do i know their name well
number one it might be in it right their
their first and last name is their
youtube channel
but one of my favorite things to do is i
would click through on their channel
still do go to their about page and look
at their about page to see if i could
find their name
or go to their social media and go to
their twitter or instagram to see if i
could find their name now that has like
some weird stock or tendencies to it
but that just shows to the degree that i
want to actually
answer that comment the difference
between just a little emoji
and potentially saying thanks jessica
your comments really meaningful and i
appreciate you
man on the other side of that like wait
how do you know my name is jessica you
know what i mean like but there's a
level of
thoughtfulness and going the extra mile
to
really make meaningful connections dale
carnegie in his book how to win friends
and influence people said remember that
a person's name
is to that person the sweetest and most
most important sound in any language
so i looked i looked for a way to just
actually go find their name
number three click on the viewers
channel and connect on twitter
so sometimes i would get a youtube
comment over the years
click through to their channel their
twitter is connected click
through to their twitter and then tweet
them to say thank you for leaving a
comment on youtube
why i'm looking for ways to make deeper
meaningful connections
i'm looking for ways to connect off
platform and really
care c-a-r-e to show that i
care and to put my my words
into actions one thing to say you care
it's another thing to put in the time
to to create content post the video edit
the video be
tired and still go the extra mile to
care for the individual number four
send twitter videos this is a whole
another level so
i've saw the youtube comment clicked
through went to twitter
now i send a video grab my phone hey you
just want to send you a quick video and
say i appreciate
you so much for taking the time to
watch one of my videos uh let me know if
there's anything i can do to help and
then being willing right maybe they
respond and here's you might already be
thinking
that like this is crazy like i've never
seen anyone if i got that that would be
insane
like that would just completely blow my
mind exactly
if you want to stand out in a sea of
sameness of social media influencers
that are mostly selfish
man you start putting the viewer first
and going the extra mile they're going
to be blown away
that you've sent them a personalized
video
to just show that you care and will go
the extra mile you can do that on
twitter
you just click a little you record a
little video do the little video feature
like figure it out make sure you update
your twitter app find the person on
twitter
send them a thank you how powerful is it
just to say thank you and if you have
the audacity
that you want full-time freedom and to
be able to write your own checks and do
what you want when you want and build
this influential youtube channel and
build a high profit youtube channel
why would you want to do that or why
would you expect to do that without
putting in the work
without potentially saying thank you
because guess how you do it
you need other people to subscribe you
need other people
to watch your videos so you get ad
revenue you need other people to click
on your affiliate links
you need other people to buy your online
course you need other people you need to
actually
serve people the power of thank you
even in a video number five
comment on their social media posts so
in addition to potentially just
responding uh and thanking them on
twitter or responding to a comment what
if you click through to their youtube
channel and comment on their video in a
meaningful way
what if you find their instagram find
that it's if it's not private if it is
i don't know if you want to follow them
now it's kind of getting weird but like
okay their instagram's public comment on
the recent post
you leave a comment on their recent
instagram post to say hey thank you so
much
for checking out one of my videos and
leaving a comment uh if you need any
more help with x whatever it is you do
i'm here to help or just you know engage
again in a meaningful way
you know what's interesting is we've
seen this happen
in a spammy way there's bots for this
there's there's algor there's software
for this
that's like you maybe have gotten bulk
dms you've gotten bulk comments you've
gotten these and i can tell i'll get
instagram comments from someone
like i can tell this is a robot this is
a canned message a canned
response this is not what i'm talking
about i am talking about
contextualized connection
creating content like it's made for the
individual but sean this will actually
take time wow yeah i mean
you're right like who would have thought
it'll actually take time
like you know that's what i had to tell
my my family the other day it was like
honey my wife was like i would love it
if you spent time with us and i was like
but that would actually take
time right but don't the people that we
love the most we need to spend time
with them and invest into them and so
invest the time and it will pay off as
you make meaningful connections on your
channel here's a few more ideas
number six instagram dms and audio
messages
so if you start connecting with someone
on instagram now maybe
your youtube channel is you know some
people are connecting with you on
instagram maybe they follow you maybe
they're dming you and if that's
happening
not only could you reply there and
potentially have that conversation
but what i love is the audio feature
like it's really easy to just hold down
the audio feature and send the person a
thank you
or just a couple days ago someone was
asking me a question
specifically related to youtube and i
think there's a 60 second time limit and
so
i did the best i could and it took me
two and a half audio messages to
answer that one person's question
i'm still at the best of my ability
trying to do this to as many people as
possible
even though now with all across all of
our channel channels we're on our way to
two million subscribers
because i learned from a leadership
mentor of mine andy stanley that you
should do for one what you wish you
should
could do for all but when you're just
starting
guess what you can do this for all like
try to do this for every single person
that comes your way
number seven answer emails maybe you get
specific emails like your emails
connected to your youtube about page
your emails may be
in your instagram bio or your social
media bio somebody wants to connect and
they actually email you
answer them it makes me think about a
friend of mine
and one of our video ranking academy
students justin co
and he would get emails and he had
kind of a faith-based question and
answer show early on
and he would get questions in his email
and he'd take 30 minutes
45 minutes an hour and a half to answer
the email
like he would invest the time into one
person into one
uh specific question to make that
meaningful connection as he was building
up his channel and his community number
eight get on the phone or zoom meeting
with people justin would do that they
would have a question he'd say like do
you want to
discuss it on the phone do you want to
discuss it on zoom now i want to
encourage you
be safe have smart boundaries and don't
do anything you're not comfortable with
and
don't you know keep it keep it pc keep
it cool
but this was awesome because him and his
wife had a real heart for helping people
and answering their questions and
helping them navigate their faith
journey
so he'd get on google hangouts or on the
phone and he would help people
one-on-one
you know eventually one of the things we
encourage you to do when you're building
up especially
education content on youtube is to
package your knowledge
in an online course that will help
people today we have a program called
video ranking academy it's our signature
youtube group coaching
program and online course um and we keep
updating it but it originally was
created back in like 2015
and we built out that course before it
was created
there was no modules there was no videos
recorded there was no site to host it
all the questions you maybe have about
all that stuff and
you know let us know what your questions
are about building out an online course
or using
your youtube channel to also you know
reach people with online courses
but one of the first things that i did
was i knew
the content i wanted to teach it was the
content that i had used
to have full-time freedom and to build a
six-figure income with affiliate
marketing and youtube and
to go full-time and before i ever taught
on youtube i'd done it on youtube by
talking about tech and camera tips and
whatnot on think media
and i uh was i had the idea for the
course
so what i did was i connected one on one
with people
and did free coaching i didn't charge
anyone didn't even offer to tr i just
was like hey can i
help you with this information by the
way
this was a way to get some to help a few
people actually get results
like before you start selling your thing
what if you actually
prove that your thing works so i was
like hey let me jump on with
uh eileen wilder and let me jump on with
postal barbecue and let me jump on and i
remember there's probably like 10
different people and i was spending
hours
i would jump on and i'd get on at the
time it was google hangouts
and basically share video ranking
academy before it became video ranking
academy
and guess what i also got was not only
did they get help and did they get my
time
but i got feedback they helped refine
the idea
they helped give me insight i got to see
where i'd maybe explain a concept but it
actually didn't really make that much
sense
and it was improved by actually
connecting with real people but then
think about this
think about how meaningful that
connection was that someone who
was making six figures with affiliate
marketing in youtube and that had a
process to do it and understood video
seo was like coaching them personally
here's what i'm encouraging you to do
look for ways to make
meaningful one-on-one connections
as it relates to your youtube channel
and that tip might not be
for you or any of these you can pick and
choose but i know
that you and me both could do better
at making meaningful connections with
people you know number nine
is answer questions on twitter quora
and facebook groups one of the
most powerful things you could do if you
have especially an education youtube
channel is people are asking questions
on twitter you know i remember back in
2009
gary vaynerchuk who's a big uh known
social media new york times bestselling
author and has a big agency
has taught a lot about social media and
he talked about how he built his twitter
to one million twitter followers
and he wrote his book in 2009 but in
2007-8 he would spend
eight hours a day answering people's
questions
on twitter about wine he had a show
called wine library tv where he reviewed
three bottles of wine
per show he did it five days a week he
did it for multiple years
he said almost nobody was watching for
the first uh year
of posting videos five days a week but
he just committed to it and not only did
he create content
listen he then engaged on social media
he didn't just post on social media like
hey go watch my stuff kind of selfish
i'm not saying you shouldn't do that but
think about what you're doing you're
asking
someone else to stop their day and come
watch you look at you watch
me look at me watch my video hit my like
button right
like you're actually saying like stop
your day and do what i want
imagine going to where people are
instagram
twitter quora facebook groups and just
helping
of course deep down your agenda
is i hope they maybe see my youtube show
i hope they maybe find my thing
but you're not doing it in such a way as
like here's half the answer and here's a
link to my channel
or here go watch this video on my
channel like meet the person right where
they are
with no expectations just knowing that a
lot of good things will happen if you
actually help people
and that really influenced me because
whether it was niche facebook groups you
know early on
i wrote a book called youtube for
churches and i was helping a lot of
people
with church content so i was in church
facebook groups church communications
facebook groups
helping serving answering questions
about youtube i answered questions on
quora which is kind of like yahoo
answers
which people are asking questions dude
if you have the answer you can answer
that question
and then you know all you have to do is
optimize your bio you're not spamming
your channel you're not linking your
channel
you're not you know linking directly to
your videos you're just optimizing your
social media bio
that if someone goes wow that was so
kind they click through
see what you're about see a clear about
me line
and see that they could click through to
watch more content on your youtube
channel you might say
well sean if i do that to 100 people or
all 100 people gonna
watch my youtube content no probably
only five will
but nevertheless when you put this much
good
out onto social media and onto youtube
pretty remarkable things happen the
thing is
just most people aren't willing to
commit to this kind of work and this
kind of investment in
people but if you become obsessed with
the viewer you take a long-term
perspective
then amazing things can happen and at
the end of the day
to me this feels a lot like love to me
this feels a lot like
really just making the world a better
place by being kind
helping people solving problems and
really making meaningful connections
you know the final one is number 10 is
then never stop
investing in the individual and i would
share this just as you grow
to make this a lifelong commitment as i
mentioned
you know we now have just i mean there's
like 7 000 people
in our video ranking academy program you
know we have uh whether it's
we have customers we have community
members we have subscribers we've got
facebook groups like we've got
so many people and so it becomes very
difficult
right to make these one-on-one
connections especially at scale
but number 10 never stop investing in
people
basically it's me saying don't stop
investing in people once you've made it
now once you've made it you have to be
that much more intentional and strategic
to really put your money where your
mouth is and here's how we do that at
think media and as you scale maybe this
will encourage you
this one thing you could do is invest in
a bigger team eventually as a social
media influencer
you can't do it all yourself and that's
one thing where we thought man if we're
going to impact more people
this whole thing has got to expand so
now that's why
heather and omar and nolan and tony and
mel and chris
and elena are connecting with people
one-to-one
sean can't connect with everybody
one-to-one but as a team we could do a
better job that's why right now
we are hiring people just to connect
with people
to answer questions to make sure they're
taken care of inside of our video
ranking academy program we're thinking
about people that are just inside of our
community and we consider our community
just like our
youtube comments and places like that
and while to this day where i realized
man i can't reach
a million people i can't dm a million
people back but i can still do
as many as i can get to every single
week i mentioned that andy stanley quote
and this is the exact quote
do for one what you wish you could do
for everyone
do for one what you wish you could do
for everyone because if we all did for
one what we wish we could do for
everyone
it might change the world but certainly
it would change one person's world and
it may
even change your world i really believe
that
that if you've got a big ambition to
build a big youtube empire
it happens one subscriber at a time
and if you focus on changing one
person's world
it just might change your world
well that value right there was
everything i mean when you think about
growing to 1 million subscribers
yes it's about the titles and the
thumbnails and making good videos
but really when you think about what
subscribers are
they're people and sean really just
broke down exactly
how you can be connecting with the
people who love what you're doing and
that's really what you're building
you're building a community of people
you're the leader
and you get to pour into that community
a couple highlights that sean said that
i wrote down
were that you want to be making self
less content
remember you are there to help people
that's why you created your channel
was so that you could be of service to
other people and i really want to just
encourage you
to lean into that that maybe sometimes
you might feel imposter syndrome come up
or maybe you don't feel like you're an
expert in something but if you've been
through something
if you've lived through something and
you want to help other people get to
where you are
then go all in and start making content
that you wish
you had when you were working through
whatever that struggle is maybe it's
weight loss or maybe
it's raising a family or maybe it's
understanding your finances and taxes
whatever it is that you've gone through
that you're creating a channel about
i just want to encourage you that
there's people on the other side of that
camera just waiting for your content
that can help them
so lean into that self less content
and then using people's name in the
comments this has been a huge help to us
here at think media because
we really are building a community of
people and i want to know the people in
the community
so using people's name when you're
responding back is such
a highlight and i hope that you use that
one tip today
when you comment back to one of your
subscribers and then lastly remember
this is really all about helping people
and as your company grows as your
youtube channel grows
it will start to feel harder and harder
to be able to connect on a one-on-one
basis to everyone
but like sean said do what you can for
one what you wish you could do for many
and always keep that in the forefront of
your company i think some of the most
successful companies right now
most successful youtube channels right
now that will live on
past just this time are the ones that
care
about people and that's what we're here
uh that's what we are all about here at
think media and i hope you felt that
through this podcast and through our
youtube channel
that we really are making content just
for you and we'd love to know what type
of content you want to hear
on the podcast you can let us know in
the comments section send us a dm
or let us know on social media so that
we can be making content that you want
to hear
and like i said at the beginning this
episode was brought to you
by our grow it video live conference
that's at growthvideolive.com
and this conference we're actually
giving away two
all-access passes to our entire
conference for free all you have to do
is rate and review this podcast
now you can do that on apple itunes you
open up your app you go right to it to
our podcast where you're listening right
now
if you're on apple and you just leave a
review there's a couple steps you need
to do to enter into win
and you can get all that information at
thethinkmarketingshow.com i'll make sure
all the information is down below
that's thinkmarketingshow.com
everything's in the description of both
the podcast as well as on youtube
so if you want to be entered in to win
one of those all access passes
all you need to do is rate and review
the podcast
and when you rate and review the podcast
you might get a shout out here from the
think team and today's shout out goes to
jason he says essential for youtube
creators
we think the same thing jason here's
what he said he said think media gives
easy to understand advice that works i
use just one of their recent tips on a
video and that video's views are
20x that of my usual videos
i can't wait to hear the next episode
jason thank you so much for being a part
of our community here at think
we are so encouraged by seeing just that
one tactic
changing the amount of views that you
have and i can't wait for you to listen
to
all of the upcoming content that we have
that's going to help you skyrocket
rocket your youtube channel
now next tuesday you're going to want to
make sure you're locked here on the
podcast
because sean is bringing a fire
interview from one of our
no miss books of this year you'll want
to make sure that you get here because
this
one book has changed everything we're
doing at think media so make sure you
tune in next tuesday
thank you so much for listening and
we'll catch you on the next episode
you